can we talk about giving dark qualities
to villains
and light qualities to heroes do the two
ever
cross over and reverse qualities ever
oh one of the things that
i think is so dramatic in a story is
where
you've got somebody who's
a little bit more on the dark side and
somebody who's
more on the light side and as the story
progresses
they cross and the person who is more
villainous becomes redeemed and the
person who started out
being all you know virtuous
then becomes villainous now that's the
just the broad strokes way to say it but
i think a wonderful example of that
is in batman in the dark knight
where you see batman who is the good guy
have to do for the sake of saving
gotham but he has to go into the
darkness
to teach the people what they need to
learn
and to help make that next step because
he's been so
blocked in what he's trying to do as the
good guy
so you see that spectrum in that one
character now
heath ledger's joker was just one thing
bad right but then you have i think it's
harvey dent as the character's name
who uh starts out supposedly doing
good things you know in politics and
great for the city and then he goes to
the dark
back and forth so watching batman the
dark knight
is a really good study on
how the dark in all of us can come out
and then how people who've been i would
say lost in the dark side
can see light and find redemption
in a lot of stories that are action
adventure military
you often find the fallen warrior
who then redeems themselves at the end
now i just saw snow piercer which is an
amazing movie all takes place on a train
and the hero of it
is a kind of a rough and tumble guy and
he's down with the dregs of society
and then he leads a rebellion and
gets to the head of the train and you
know to save things and change the
system but what we find out is that
some time ago he was so hungry as a lot
of people were down there he was going
to eat this baby
because all those people had to turn to
cannibalism
and an older man down there said no
here take my arm and he cut off his arm
and gave it to
the protagonist so that he wouldn't eat
the baby
as the story progresses the child has
grown up
to about five years old and the hero is
trying to rescue the child
and his friend who had cut his arm off
gets killed in rebellion
okay fast forward to the end of it
in order to save the day and save the
child
he has to put his arm into the machinery
so it's that moment of redemption when
he does a self-sacrifice
that is very much in line with the bad
thing that he had done and i love that
symmetry
where someone sacrifices themself in the
same way
that they brought about their own fall
you